les symboles de la république la
république à quatre principaux symboles
le drapeau tricolore
son hymne national marianne est sa
devise
le drapeau bleu blanc rouge s'est imposé
au moment de la révolution de 1789 le
drapeau blanc et que celui de la
monarchie dont du roi les couleurs de
paris était le bleu et le rouge
et comme c'est paris qui s'est d'abord
soulevé les révolutionnaires ont fait du
bleu blanc rouge leur cocarde qui
s'accrochaient à leur gilet et sur leurs
chapeaux
au début les trois couleurs reflétait
l'unité de la nation avec son roi au
pouvoir amoindrie puisque le blanc est
coincé entre le bleu et le rouge
c'était avant que l'on décide d'abolir
complètement le pouvoir royal même l'
empire de napoléon à garder les trois
couleurs mais à la restauration de la
monarchie en 1814
le nouveau roi louis xviii rétabli le
drapeau blanc à fleur de lys c'est en
1830 que le bleu blanc rouge s'impose
définitivement grâce à louis philippe
qui se fait appeler roi des français et
non roi de france en arborant le drapeau
tricolore de républicains
les trois couleurs sont maintenant
partout sur les bâtiments publics et
peinturluré sur la figure des
supporteurs de l'équipe de france au
début des matches de l'équipe de france
justement on chante la marseillaise
en 1792 le roi d'autriche déclare la
guerre à la france révolutionnaire
rouget de lisle un officier français
composent dans la nuit du 25 au 26 avril
ce chant de guerre un chant tellement
entraînant qu'il ait repris sur tout le
territoire et c'est un bataillon de
révolutionnaire venu de marseille pour
se battre contre les autrichiens qui l'a
rendu célèbre en défilant à paris
cette année là marianne est un autre
symbole de la république
la première représentation de cette
femme au bonnet phrygien est un célèbre
tableau d'eugène delacroix représentant
la liberté guidant le peuple lors de la
révolution de 1830
mais c'est à partir de 1872 au début de
la troisième république que les bustes
de marianne ont été installées dans les
mairies
on voulait que la république prennent
une allure protectrice et rassurante
comme une maman à peu sévère enfin
liberté égalité fraternité c'est la
devise de la république
ces trois mots sont inscrits sur toutes
les écoles et toutes les mairies il
synthétise la déclaration des droits de
l'homme qui a été élaboré en 1789
ce sont des objectifs jamais vraiment
atteint mais vers lesquels nous devons
tendre les symboles ne sont que des
symboles des images des représentations
des couleurs mais une communauté en
l'occurrence pour nous la république a
aussi besoin de rites et de signes de
ralliement pour pouvoir faire vivre
ensemble tous ses membres